To make this process of simplifying even more rewarding Mozilla would offer rewards.
For five problems simplified, a volunteer would be invited to the Mozilla launch party.
For ten test cases simplified, he or she would also get an attractive stuffed animal
the Mozilla mascot.
For 20 test cases one would get a t-shirt signed by the grateful engineers.
Let's see whether I can earn a stuffed animal.
Let's remove this part.
We invoke Mozilla. Failure still is there.
We remove another part, invoke Mozilla, failure is still there.
We remove another part, see how it gets simpler and simpler,
and the failure still is there. Mozilla still crashes.
Now I'm going to remove this entire Bugzilla page to a single line.
If I now invoke Mozilla and invoke print, Mozilla crashes.